changer pour de vue une crabes
sacré thème on dirait un
sujet de bac philo en tout cas c'est
comme ça que je les ai reçus canton
voyez et des traces du nietzsche deviens
ce que tu es le surhomme et en même
temps on aurait bien besoin de super
héros non pour faire face au changement
climatique
le truc c'est que super héros ça
n'existe pas alors que le changement
climatique va il est bien réelle et
c'est écrasant je fais partie des
personnes qui ressentent beaucoup de
colère beaucoup de frustration à l'idée
que les choses n'avancent pas assez vite
que ça va pas assez loin et certainement
pas pour tout le monde
et honnêtement moi ces sujets climatique
j'y suis venu et je me consacre une
bonne partie de ma vie pour des question
d'humanité pas par passion pour une
grenouille verte d'amazonie ou pour un
ours polaire mais parce que il s'agit de
s'assurer ou en tout cas de faire tout
ce qui est en notre pouvoir pour que les
3,3 milliards d'êtres humains dont le
giec nous rappellent quotidiennement ou
presque que ils vont être
subir massivement les conséquences du
changement climatique
il ya qu'on puisse laisser une chance de
vivre sans être trop bouleversée à ses
3,3 milliards note heureusement et moi
c'est ça c'est pour ça que je suis
debout c'est pour ça que je suis ici
c'est pour ça que j'agis tous les jours
dans cette direction
alors j'ai désolé de plomber l'ambiance
en plus je commence
et c'est pas toujours très sympathique
tout ça
mais ça fait une vingtaine d'années
maintenant que je suis je me disais tout
à l'heure je suis investisseurs chez
entrepreneur je suis active dans le
domaine de la finance et de
l'entrepreneuriat je soutiens en temps
en argent dans des start up et des
projets impact social environnemental
fort
je m'implique et je crée je participe
dans des projets qui soutiennent la
place des femmes dans l'économie
accessoirement juste la moitié de
l'humanité et les trois quarts des
décisions consommation dans le monde
parenthèse refermée donc
je les forme encourage et puis parfois
je tape aussi du poing sur la table pour
faire que leur voix leur cash et leur
talent en compte
voilà trois sujets les femmes le climat
et la justice sociale voilà ce qui anime
mais journée et ce à quoi je consacre ma
vie depuis maintenant une bonne dizaine
d'années alors peut-être qu'avec ce cv
vous espériez vous vous attendiez à ce
que je chante les louanges des start up
de la kleine tech de la finance verte
qui va sauver le monde des éco gestes
des colibris tout ça et peut-être même
que vous disiez bas super va nous parler
diversité que c'est une chance que dans
les femmes elles n'ont qu'a osé après
touba elle est là pourquoi ne devrait
pas les femmes
bref vous répéter ce que vous entendez à
longueur de journée alors pour être
clair tout de suite c'est pas du tout le
genre de la maison le genre de la maison
c'est d'être too much on me l'a dit on
l'a répété depuis que j'ai commencé à
travailler que j'étais trop jeune au
début trop ambitieuse trop agressive
trop énergique propre intelligent trop
brillante
plein de qualificatifs trop speed trop
direct trop émotive trop gentil trop
idéaliste bon pas assez française aussi
je suis né en algérie et l'essentiel de
ma famille vit là bas et vous n'imaginez
pas le nombre de fois où lorsque je
rencontrais une personne à titre
professionnel pour la première fois
personne vous dit ça vient d'où ils
mènent oui mais si d'où vous venez d'où
et mes collègues on leur demandait rien
et c'est pas évident à gérer vous voyez
tous ces qualificatifs un peu excessif
que j'ai reçues et qu'on me disait
régulièrement quand on est une femme
dans un métier où les femmes sont encore
très rares et particulièrement c'est le
cas de l'investissement alors quand on
est une femme tout much
au secours
on m'a fait me sentir mais tellement mal
entropa à ma place en reconnaissant
quand même que c'était bien pratique
toutes les qualités too much c'est bien
pratique pour faire face à des projets
qui semblent impossibles des projets ou
vraiment le processus normal impossible
ça marche pas pour embarquer ou résoudre
des situations elle aussi qui semblait
désespérée
pour inventer des procédures dont on
n'avait jamais entendu parler
et moi j'y allais avec une espèce de
confiance presque naïve en disant mais
oui je parle des problèmes je sais pas
les gérer ben on va y aller à fond et
puis mon équipe on va y arriver presque
naïf ne meurent pas
et je sais pas comment j'ai fait
honnêtement pour résoudre tous ces
problèmes je sais juste que j ai laissé
beaucoup de plumes et pas mal de l'âme
c'était vraiment pas c'était vraiment
pas facile tous les jours
la chose en revanche c'est que mes
équipes elles ont toujours beaucoup
appris à mes côtés ça c'est sûr et je
suis émue aux larmes quand je pense à
mes jeunes stagiaires met en scène
stagiaires qui aujourd'hui ont des
parcours professionnels incroyable
tout mais des entrepreneurs qui est
petit snobé pendant des années par tout
un tas de financiers disent on dit
classique et qui m'a appelé à minuit
pour retrouver de la force quoi
l'énergie et les idées claires
comme quoi la too much là qui est un peu
à côté du car mais elles aident à
grandir
donc ces pratiques puis elle est pas que
a grandi elle aide aussi à faire du
profit puisque ben mes idées de l'espace
les fameuses d'idées tout match elle
faisait gagner des millions à nos
clients n'ont donc en somme bas comme je
bouscule est d'un côté mais que de
l'autre côté c'était profitable pour
plein de gens donc finalement jeté
tolérer tolérée mais je ne me suis
jamais sentie vraiment accepter
pleinement et ça depuis l'âge de 15 ans
quand j'ai débarqué complètement par
hasard
alalou le grand lycée parisien
avec hazard chanceux qui m'ont amené là
et depuis cet âge-là je n'ai cessé
d'avoir l'impression de devoir meurent à
petit ses
rentrées dans une petite case qu'on m'a
signé dans un petit coin il est trop
petit pour moi
et j'ai dû faire pas mal de sacrifices
personnels qui franchement a posteriori
me semble un peu inutile
la diversité la façon dont moi je
n'incarne c'est ma manière d'être au
monde c'est une manière qui pique un peu
les yeux parfois et ça ça gêne
et les entreprises le monde de
l'entreprise est tout à fait disposé à
considérer la diversité mais pour autant
qu'elles restent à sa petite place à
celle qu'on lui a assigné notamment pour
parler de diversité ça oui alors pour
parler d'autres sujets pas sûr et encore
moins quand on aurait l'impudence
l'insolence de vouloir faire bouger les
lignes en profondeur dans cette fameuse
organisation
ça et bien dans ces conditions on vous
garde à l'écart et puis au fur et à
mesure vont vous fait on signifie que
vous devenez un pot l'érable ce que vous
devez de vous devenue dangereuse
vous voyez c'est pas une succès story 1
ses 20 ans d'expérience c'est pas y'a
pas de l'apn vraiment pas pour autant
je suis là aujourd'hui parce que j'ai
envie de vous offrir cette expérience
parce que je pense qu'elle peut vous
profitez 1 vous vous qui m'écoutent et
elle peut vous profiter pour vous lever
et pour agir de manière puissante dans
les entreprises peut-être que certains
d'entre vous sont déjà ça j'ai un
certain son collaborateur collaboratrice
dans des entreprises montreux preneur
pour agir de manière puissante
aujourd'hui dans vos entreprises pour
lutter contre le changement climatique
ce que le défi est gigantesque il y est
impensable et l humanité on n'a jamais
fait face à un défi d'une telle ampleur
dans le timing c'est à dire pour
avant-hier et puis en plus l'ampleur des
transformations qui est nécessaire
c'est pas une transformation qui va
nécessiter qui va se suffire du principe
de bon bah on a juste un peu on fait
presque comme avant et puis ça ira parce
que ça c'est la recette garantie pour le
statu quo ces garanties
et comme collectivement aujourd'hui
franchement on n'a aucune idée personne
n'a aucune idée de comment très très
concrètement dans le détail entreprise
par entreprise pays par pays
thématique par thématique
on va arriver à décarbonés assez vite et
assez fort pour
avoir une chance et puis ils sont pour
autant totalement faire exploser nos
démocraties au passage et puis pas trop
provoquer de révoltes de la faim à
droite à gauche quelques conflits armés
peut-être éviter tout ça bon enfin
surtout si on décide de faire ça chacun
dans notre petit coin
et le bouquin magique
décarbonés pour les nuls en cinq ans il
n'existe pas même le giec s'y est pas
risquer trace des pistes des
méthodologies possible mais surtout il
nous engage
il nous supplient collectivement de nous
engager massivement et de faire le pari
de la sobriété qui est le pari crédible
pas d'imaginer que d'hypothétiques
technologies émergentes nous permettront
surtout surtout ne renoncer à rien
jamais
et pour pouvoir avancer vers ce chemin
là ça suppose qu'on ait une prise de
conscience tous et toutes et là j'ai pas
une très bonne nouvelle pour vous et
pour moi d'ailleurs c'est qu'en fait on
est tous des activistes de
l'accélération du changement climatique
parce que tous et toutes dans nos jobs
on est en train de consommer activement
des ressources non renouvelables en tout
cas la plupart d'entre nous on est en
train de consommer ces ressources non
renouvelables alors le vélo pour aller
au boulot les recyclage de bouteilles
d'eau et tout c'est sympa on se dit
qu'on est une personne bien mais ça ne
suffit pas et tant qu'on n'a pas pris la
mesure de sa non pourra pas agir d'une
manière suffisamment puissante
et ça c'est une sacrée réalisation et
vous pensez peut-être que j'exagère
peut-être mais moi je me mets dedans
avec vous
alors on peut se dire bon bah c'est très
très dur d'abandonner ses privilèges ça
tu abandonné ses avantages et je sais à
quel point c'est difficile et je sais
aussi à quel point c'est dur de lutter
contre ses instincts ses instincts de
croissance d'expansion très très dur moi
je vous le dis je suis investisseurs et
entrepreneurs mandant tropisme c'est de
pousser les boîtes à grandir plus de
chiffre d'affaires push de cash plus de
salariés plus d'impact c'est ça mon
tropisme cause d'imaginer il faut que je
fasse que je me tordre c'est hyper
paradoxal
hyper paradoxal parce que d'un autre
côté ça suppose aussi de se dire mais
est ce que cette boîte a le mérite
d'exister est ce qu'elle mérite de
consommer ces ressources d'employer ses
talents au service d'un demain qui nous
sera utile collectivement ou pas
ça c'est une question qui est hyper
perturbante et vous voyez je me la pose
et je ne me ménage pas clairement pas
autre sujet assez désagréable
l'industrie du textile qui est hyper
polluantes et qui a des pratiques
sociales
douteuses à l'autre bout du monde bon
ben l'industrie du textile qu'est ce
qu'on fait on remet tout à plat ou alors
est-ce qu'il faut vraiment créer de
nouvelles marques responsable je sais
pas est-ce que la seconde main qui est
présenté par tout le monde comme ça y
est l'eldorado mais est-ce que c'est pas
une façon de se déculpabiliser en
consommant en faisant du shopping
tranquille ou peut-être
moi j'ai toute ma vie j'ai adoré faire
du shopping toute ma vie par plaisir par
voilà par bout de la mode aussi par
maîtrise et envie de maîtriser l'image
que je renvoie aux autres comme plein de
faim et socialement c'était important
pour moi mais en 2017 j'ai fait un semis
burnout
et j'ai pris trois tailles de vêtements
en quelques semaines résultat ma
garde-robe un oubli un jeune a plus rien
qui m'allait j'ai pas mise à la poubelle
mais je n'ai pas remplacés donc depuis
cinq ans j'ai acheté quelques pièces à
droite à gauche
j'ai surtout renoncer à ma coquetterie
légendaire qui faisait tellement partie
2 identité et puis pour laquelle je ne
suis pas mal battu parce que
pointez-vous dans une salle de réunion à
billets comme sahbi ajouté maquiller
dans les salles de réunions avec des
financiers tous habillés en bleu et en
or et puis essayer d'être prise au
sérieux puis on en reparle
alors voyez depuis cinq ans j'ai cessé
d'habiter ce corps de m'habituer et
venir à vous aujourd'hui ce n'était pas
évident c'était pas facile pour moi
d'accepter parce que je sais à quel
point le regard qui est posé sur les
femmes il peut être très très dur mais
justement si j'ai accepté si j'ai décidé
de venir vous voir aujourd'hui est de me
présenter avec toute ma vulnérabilité
mais aussi mon expérience mes échecs etc
c'est pour partager avec vous un instant
de vie c'est
savez le philosophe bernard stiegler il
parlait de la bifurcation c'est la
différence entre ce que le big data peut
sortir c'est à dire sous traitement de
données d'informations qui sont connus
la différence entre ça les petits pas
l'incrémentation le progrès incrémentale
et 1% par an et puis les sauts les sauts
de créativité humaine ce qui fait que on
peut collectivement
créer une nouvelle réalité
la bifurcation cessa l'ampleur de son
hôte on a besoin pour faire face au
changement climatique la bifurcation
s'est parlé de train fou tout à l'heure
où on était tous d accélérateur de
changement climatique on avait tous la
[ __ ] sur le à fond sur le pas sur le
frein mais au contraire sur la [ __ ]
d'accélérateur
mais la bifurcation c'est le frein dans
le train c'est ont construit un méga
hélicoptère pour embarquer les wagons de
devant un pour réduire l'intensité du
choc s'est construit un méga airbags sur
le mur pour faire que même si à chocques
bail sera un peu absorbé vous trouvez
que j'exagère mais c'est salle en pleurs
l'intensité l'engagement dont on a
besoin pour se donner une chance
collectivement c'est ça
bien sûr on peut se dire
la bifurcation mais c'est juste
peut-être des petits pas supplémentaire
mais non on parle de saut de saut de
penser contre soi même de sauts dont on
se dit mais non ils ne sont pas
possibles l'autre jour il ya une
start-up tech qui a qui est venu qui m'a
habitué son projet et ils ont une
technologie incroyable pour un briquet
de l'eau potable super
croyable sauf que dans le schéma dans
lequel ils sont ils vont fabriquer de
l'eau potable plutôt pour la vendre à
des personnes qui aujourd'hui utilisent
de l'eau en bouteille
bon parce que c'est plus réaliste parce
que ben c'est plus finançables par des
financiers des investisseurs
vous l'avez bien compris avec mon oeil
too much plus climatique justice sociale
aujourd'hui mais je posais la question
qui fâche mais puisque vous êtes aussi
innovant pourquoi est-ce que vous n'êtes
pas extrêmement innovants ainsi qu'au
fait pas ce saut dont je parlais de
bifurcation
aussi au niveau du modèle d'impact au
niveau du financement
pourquoi vous le faite que pour la
techno
voilà alors aujourd'hui je suis là
aujourd'hui c'est pour vous nous donner
cette force là cette force de faire ses
sauts je suis là pour vous dire que vous
avez tous et tout même si vous êtes en
tant que salarié même si vous êtes
junior vous avez le pouvoir de porter un
regard ouvert ou fermé sur les idées de
vos collègues de dire ah oui pourquoi
pas est d'enrichir et d'enchaîner est
pas un an et problème c'est que
vous le connaissez le problème c'est qu
on aime bien ça en france nos normes et
le problème c'est que
si je suis là aujourd'hui
c'est pour vous partager
notamment pour les managers pour les
futurs entrepreneurs peut-être parmi
vous vire au leader aussi que l'idée de
destruction de destruction créatrice de
schopenhauer bas cette fameuse
destruction créatrice pourquoi est-ce
qu'on utiliserait pas aussi pour
soutenir la vie pour faire que peut-être
certaines entreprises aujourd'hui on
devrait les laisser mourir
les plus polluantes qui depuis des
années des années n'ont pas fait grand
chose
donc
voila mon message aujourd'hui donc
j'aimerais qu'on fasse
j'ai qu'une demande à vous faire une
dernière j'aimerais qu'on fasse tous
collectivement un pari le pari de
l'excès comme levier pour lutter contre
le changement climatique
pour aller au-delà de ce qu'on nous dit
sur instagram les stations inspirante
accepter ce qui est au delà de notre du
contrôle et puis se satisfaire non non
se satisfait pas ce que le changement
climatique il est en dehors nous de nos
contrôles et pour autant il faut qu'on
se lève pour l'adresser
mon prénom c'est iman ça veut dire foi
et espoir et j'espère sincèrement que
collectivement on se donnera la chance
voilà j'espère que c'est pas too much
comme espoir